ich mache es kurz hallo leute ich wieder
einmal waren willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender aus prag video heute
machen wir den
ddp
heute gibt es den e mails kalender der
emp adventskalender kann für 19 euro 99
auch bei dir zu hause sein weil das
gerade wie ein werbeslogan klang dieses
videos nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle
dieses video ist nicht gespannt sein
wir waren so heiß auf diesen
adventskalender und irgendwas sagt mir
dann wird halt dass ihr schadenfroh seit
ich glaube mir seit schaden ehrlich
gesagt ich auch und ich habe
informationen darüber bekommen dass der
beauty tendenz kalender rates verteilt
wird also wahrscheinlich haben sie damit
nicht den besten deal gemacht und ich
bin wirklich gespannt was sie sich hier
gedacht haben dieses mal haben wir nicht
beringt corti gefragt sondern akzente
der ist designed in germany parabene
free und wegen wiegen friendly und diese
adventskalender ist made in der
volksrepublik china
schaffst es aber auch so geil sagt wenz
kalender kann nicht stehen hat aber auch
kein vorbereitetes loch also man soll
ihn einfach legt ihn euch einfach
irgendwohin bruder schon ganzen stern
bekommen auf der website ich will ganz
kurz mal dieser akzent ruddy haben sogar
eine instagram seite wachsen was
produzieren die sonst noch ohne dich ist
alles doof ich habe noch nie etwas davon
gehört sieht jetzt aber nicht drum also
sieht aus wie eine süße seite von einem
kosmetik hersteller also ist jetzt
nichts daran auszusetzen wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass es noch sein kann
das irgendwie aus seinen fehlern gelernt
hat er kostet nichts 70 euro das ist
schon mal ein großes plus
und wir werden mal schauen dass wir
damit zu machen aber da es hier um
wellness geht was wir uns gut
vorbereiten gewissen druck
ja das ist möglich machten uns ein
richtig schön wellnesstag leute wohl
durch einen tee macht euch eine
duftkerze an jetzt mit gewesen ist
wir starten mit dem türchen nummer es
ist ein kalender für 19 euro 99 deswegen
können wir nicht erwarten dass hier
irgendwie krasses packaging dabei ist
wir müssen dem ihr auch eine chance
geben ein shampoo also eine shampoo
probe schön weihnachtlich dekoriert zeit
made in china aber made in china heißt
vanille und masken us masters ist maske
nicht sehr schön und besteht jetzt nicht
wofür das shampoo sein soll aber ich
denke mal es ist ein stinknormales
stammte ja es ist ein wellness kalender
da war jetzt ein shampoo drin beschweren
können uns nachher weniger kirchentags
ich weiß dass jetzt viele erp kunden
sagen werden waren das ist gar nicht
typisch mp weil so ein bisschen dieses
rocky gefehlt klingt peinlich wenn ich
das sage es tut mir leid aber ihr wisst
hoffentlich was ich meine
rhade fischer was ist da drin also auch
nach diesem wandel und gut riechen
essbare herz natürlich enorm 3
geil wäre es eigentlich gewesen wenn ich
das video aus dem badezimmer gedreht
hatte wieder einen christmas ii lok
winter is the time for home es ist alles
in diesem vanilleduft ja noch eine
badekur jetzt halt in runde dass man
sich wundert warum siehst also es ist
exakt das gleiche
warum haben sie hier in sticker drauf
geklebt und da einfach so nicht ja das
ist genau das gleiche produkt halt
anders geformt für eine leichte
enttäuschung durch meinen körper
durchziehen aber davon lassen wir uns
nicht beirren wollen fair sein türchen
nummer vier wenn das
es gibt es bei rasch auch das ist eine
rose und die blätter sind quasi seife
wenn ich mich nicht irre
riecht ein bisschen muffig aber nicht
schlecht so ironisch das ist hat einen
badewannen duschen mache ich verstehe
halt immer noch nicht wo die zielgruppe
erreicht wird wenn emp ein
adventskalender bands kalender
rausbringt der halt einfach genauso von
bibi und tina sein könnte die seife
recht wir die war schon offen
die da jetzt umgegangen und die ganze
zeit oder wie es geht ja wie eine
stinknormale seife in tannenbaum vor
sie kann sogar stehen war so nikolaus
keilwerth auch gewesen wenn diese ganzen
badeartikel und so schwarz gewesen wären
irgendwie so dieses thema von mp hätten
das ist das body scrub ein peeling also
es heute glaube ich alles diesen
vanilleduft und jetzt cremen wir uns ein
ja das ist eine gute creme also sie
riecht nicht zu doll
hier wird leider nicht gesagt wie man es
anwendet aber ein körperpeeling dachte
ich mache man unter der dusche sind
kleine päckchen
ich finde nullrunde im körper lotion
wieder in vanille
wer kennt es nicht sich vor dem baden
schön einzucremen
die eigentlich menschen die gerne baden
oder nicht ich weiß das ist eine große
diskussion ich bin jemand der sehr gerne
badet aber es gibt auch viele die mich
anrufen und sagen wie kannst du nur ja
es ist eine körperlotion also die is
fresh die es gibt nicht sehr sehr
strange das alles hier stellt euch mal
vor ich wollte diesen adventskalender
eigentlich dafür 30 euro verkaufen aber
nach den letzten wahlen die wie kommt
das 20 macht türchen nummer
[Applaus]
also wirklich praktisch also ich mich
meinen gerade ernst sind diese bürste
liegt perfekt so in der hand
ich muss sagen ich habe nur so eine
große bürste im unter den nägeln und so
sauber zu machen beim waschen ist es
nämlich sehr praktisch gerade zur
heutigen zeit dass man sich auch mit
einer bürste so schön unter den nägeln
richtig schrubbt er strange lieh mir das
ganze heer will kommen sehr gut voran
ist etwas was glaube ich nicht viele zu
hause haben und das hat man dann
wirklich schluss jetzt kommt meint ihr
ich natürlich noch mal neun leute ich
glaube dieser red ich bin ein bisschen
hey ich bin ein bisschen hektisch nummer
9 mit mich jetzt komplett umbauen
naja braucht man für einen wellnesstag
die nummer langsam bekomme ich hotel
badezeug babes nie wisst was ich meine
sag mir bitte nicht dass das immer
genauso in hotels steht dankeschön ich
meine perfekte hsg also das ist ich
glaube aber gerade deswegen weil das
halt so wirklich hotel qualität j j hat
ist einfach so was willst du ein
schlechtes dagegen sagen aber es gibt es
auch nichts was besonders geil
es wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nach
vanille und messgeräten ich muss mal
ganz kurz google das heißt denn meist
gretel on mars moschus deswegen aber
auch eigentlich luft das ganze zeit will
ich aber nicht so bewies duschwanne lag
cup cakes sondern so will das riecht
nach vanille verstanden natürlich nummer
11 1 5 steigen
das ist ein stein und mit diesem stein
kann man sich an der hacke die hornhaut
abkuppeln ich hab kein also ich bin
happy
ja wir machen weiter füllen darf nicht
fehlen
nagl tage um da kann man auch nichts
falsch machen das jetzt ist jetzt zeit
es ist eine nagel zahl 13
meine sorge der nächste festgeländes von
einem nagel ding rein wenn meine nägel
kürze da rede ich über nägeln und ziehe
eine hand und nagel creme raus also bis
jetzt habe ich nur zu beanstanden dass
ich noch nicht sehe wie die zielgruppe
von emp damit beglückt wird doch jetzt
wo ich jetzt wo ich länger den duft
riecht ich bin fan glaube der ist auch
tatsächlich für mann/frau alle irgendwie
angenehm
meine hände fühlen sich fantastisch an
was soll ich sagen
produkte bis 2020 überraschend beide mit
präsident der ehe b kalender ist doch
ganz okay jetzt alles wieder besser
sichern um 8 14
ich denke jetzt gerade an mich und
natürlich ich habe schon badesachen da
und ich kaufe mir alles wenn ich es
brauche aber wenn ich jetzt meine nichte
denkt oder so die wird sich nie da
glaube ich freuen über so ein set von
scream revolution
was ist der unterschied zwischen body
cream und körperlotionen das werden
jetzt wissenschaftlich herausfinden ich
habe ein bisschen body cream finger
macht dann eben ein bisschen
körperlotionen was fühlt sich identische
halte den unterschied zwischen
körperlotionen und body green kennt
schreibt ihn jetzt in die kommentare
[Musik]
nummer 15 kann halt seine kundschaft
nicht nicht aber ich liebe ich habe noch
nie eine goldene nagelfeile gesehen
ich glaube die goldene seite fällt nicht
aber die andere seite viel
wahrscheinlicher sind jedes türchen
irgendwie euro wert aber ich bin auf
jeden fall spannend wir müssen nochmal
den hersteller so ein bisschen
recherchieren 16 funktion das kann ich
nicht schon cool gerade so eine fusion
man hat ab und zu mal so ein tag da
möchte man sich diesen ganzen wellness
können es in die füsse
schleifen zehennägel schneiden über eine
richtige handcreme benutzen ich weiß
nicht was jetzt eine fußcreme von einer
anderen creme unterscheidet aber es
irgendwie es dafür total süß wenn man
wird jetzt nicht denken dass es von dem
eben hat wenn es kann denn das aber das
was hier drinnen sieht halt sieht
schöner aus türchen nummer blieb habt
ihr manchmal auch in diesem moment dass
wir singen und dann denkt ihr für eine
sekunde kann ich sehen dann erinnert ihr
euch
nein ich weiß nicht warum aber sie haben
alle produkte diesen adventskalender
rein geklebt ist so schwer die russen
ziehen
warum stück sei für dieses mal in
schneeflocken vorgehen frischer die
folie gewickelt aber wie es ja es ist
halt ein kleines stück seife natürlich
nochmal 18
die haben alles getan also ich spüre
hier einen positiveren weit von dem
make-up adventskalender beauty make-up
links auf das geländer warum verkauft
ihr das sieben euro teurer das möchte
ich mal dran ich weiß aber noch nicht ob
es daran liegt dass ich einfach so gerne
bade aber das ist praktisch das ist okay
das ist genauso eine weihnachtszeit ist
sehr stressig ist und so finde ich schon
adventskalender schon sehr cool wo dann
tut man eh genug das heißt schokolade
kann man sich sparen man kann noch ein
bisschen
[Musik]
das einzige was ich weiß ist halt wie
preis leistung ist aber die produkte
gefallen
man hat sogar ein bisschen schwarz dabei
wir sind sogar weihnachtlich gestaltet
jetzt machen wir weiter mit der nummer
19 da kleber das schöne schöne schachtel
ich sage gar nichts gegen diese
schachtel die ist wunderschön aber halt
das gleiche wie gut man muss aber auch
irgendwie die tücher erfüllen ich will
jetzt hier auch im klimaschutz nehmen
was mit mir passiert psyche nummer 20
deswegen wollte ich die nägel hat wenn
es keine feuer aus packen aber das ist
eine gerät kommt einfach nicht was ich
brauche goldenen balls haben jetzt
bekommt wie wild aus wie dragon balls
wahrscheinlich so allgemeinwissen aber
ich habe keine ahnung was es ist es
riecht nach wanne lohn war das türchen
21 wir sind in den zwanzigern angekommen
sind gleich am ziel
jetzt werden sie hier aber um kreativ na
jetzt haben wir natürlich noch schwer zu
fallen wir haben wieder einen banner
fischer und da ist eigentlich nur so
jungen drin und verfügen also ich glaube
es macht nichts anderes außer einmal
kurz pudel modersohn jung sehr gut für
die haut sind damit schon 44 badeborn
aber außer die vier bade bomben und die
zwei seiten hat sich glaube ich nichts
wiederholt ihr habt mich nicht
enttäuscht ich bin stolz auf euch in 22
sternwarte konfetti sterne die man sich
sorgt die badewanne machen kann dann
gehst du nein sternen bad baden wenn du
dann noch aus baden-baden kommst warum
bin ich eigentlich ungeschminkt in
diesem video aussehen durch ist wahr
dass richtiges deutsch
naja ich das hätte ich mir halt hier
gerade die sparkasse ihr nummer 23
letztes vor letztes türchen wird noch
einmal eine wahre bombe drin sein wenn
ja jetzt welche enttäuscht vier bomben
reichen hier kommt der kleine range hier
kommen um noch ein bahre fischer das
unnötigste produkt von allen hier drin
so jetzt was bekommen wir an weihnachten
wird es noch mal 110 später ich bin ganz
kurz aus dem erp juti adventskalender
kann die 24 einfach keiner toppen ich
habe es gesagt das ist ein beschissenes
24 türchen was bekommen wir in der 24
bmp beauty es ist weihnachten man denn
zu seinem kalender schon viel zu doll
eingecremt und viel zu oft gebadet mit
den ganzen bade film aber mit den
schwimmhäuten greift man sich die 24
öffnet sie und findet ein schaumbad und
das ein bisschen spielt ja
das war der kalender ich meine es ist
keine nebenher adventskalender wir
müssen mal hier also wir bleiben mal
neutral so produkte sind okay es ist es
ist ein wellness adventskalender das
sind beides produkte sehen nicht ganz
die brücke zwischen mp und diesen
produkten vielleicht versucht er sich
langsam in der bluesszene
einzuschleichen
wir gehen noch mal ein bisschen dem
hersteller auf die spur und es gibt den
akzent radwanska länder also irgendwie
ich geschenkt dass mich alle der
adventskalender hat das gleiche
frontdesign wie diese produkte und nicht
so ja und da wird halt gemeldet und es
sind exakt den gleichen sachen drin
nummer 20 ist nummer 20
bade perlen a ach das ist kein
die rose die rose ist auch bade konfetti
dann reißt du quasi diese rosenblätter
ab und legt sie so über amazon gibt es
auch aha aber mit make-up anscheinend
schafft es diese marke ugg central falls
sie falsch ausspreche tut es mir leid
sie schafft es individuelle verpackungen
zu machen wie zum beispiel hier bei
diesen süßen reh fuchs dingen star sind
dicker für die gemacht wurden und es ist
so beklebt und dann gibt's halt den
akzent ra believe in magic
adventskalender mit diesem design dann
gibt es aber noch den akzent ramona
adventskalender mit einem passenden
design dafür es sind die ähnlichen
produkte bzw
fast identisch außer der rasierer und
einen kam und eine reise zahnbürste und
dann halt wahrscheinlich aftershave und
so'n quatsch aber individual so das ist
passend zu diesem männer adventskalender
iwannek center verkauft den für den
gleichen preis das bedeutet emp versucht
sich nicht extra plus da drauf zu machen
aber warum nehmt ihr einfach das gleiche
was in diesen anderen kalendern drinnen
macht eine schwarze verpackung damit man
vielleicht denkt aktuell das ist schwarz
ich bin locker ich bin gott ich bin
keine ahnung ich mag halt gerne schwarz
und hole mir dann halt denen und
bekommen dann aber die gleichen guten
designs wie halt für so ne also es ist
kein stück also ich würde ihn jetzt
nicht hätten wegen den produkten weil
das ist ja man bekommt man bekommt das
was man quasi bezahlt weil ich leistung
scheint das ist jetzt hier nicht
bombastisch aber ich glaube es ist jetzt
auch nicht der größte fan liebt das
gefühl mp war so nah dran die haben sich
gesagt okay beziehen leute nicht erst
das sind normale produkte da drin wir
schreien wenn s drauf was erwarten die
leute wenn sie wellness adventskalender
kaufen aber am ende sind sie doch am
ziel vorbei gelaufen irgendwer hat in
irgendeiner abteilung wieder komplett
falls eine person von emp zuschaut
vielleicht auch die personen die
verantwortlich für diesen
adventskalender sind ich habe nichts
gegen euch person
ich möchte nicht dass ihr nach hause
wieder und irgendwie schlecht fühlt ihr
lasst euch wahrscheinlich von mir eh
nicht sagen aber was ist das da bei euch
so ich hoffe euch habt ein
ungeschminktes gesicht gefallen und ihr
seid von meiner schönheit nicht zu sehr
geblendet worden schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare aus dem adventskalender
halte bleibt nett und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder nicht allzu bald denn
es gibt noch ein paar kalender dann geht
ab erster dezember wieder block mit
lohse ich freue mich sehr darauf ich
habe schon einige sachen mir überlegt
wahrscheinlich werde ich nur die hälfte
davon umsetzen aber dafür liebt dem ich
am ende des tages
vergesst das ist dann bis zum nächsten
[Musik]